so let's dive into supporting touch
events presuming that you really need to
touch is supported across all major
mobile browsers and chrome firefox and
opera and desktop as well
so touch has its own set of events touch
start touch move touch end and touch
cancel these are somewhat analogous to
the mouse events mouse down mouse move
and mouse up
although mouse events have only one
pointer so the target element and
coordinates of the mouse event are just
on the event object but touch events are
multi-touch so there are three lists of
touches on each touch event object all
the active touches all the touches that
are affecting the current dom element
and all the change touches
in each of these lists each individual
touch is represented by an object that
contains a unique identifier for the
touch the coordinates of the touch
and the target dom element in the page
although this is an important difference
touch events are always delivered to the
element that first received that touch
they don't walk across element
boundaries like mouse events do so it's
important to hook the right elements
in fact it's a good idea to add the
touch end handler during your touch
start handler
and keep in mind too that even if you
remove a dom element from your tree it
still gets the events until the touch
ends